Speaker 1: Let's go next to oh, there's some
interesting folks here, some interesting folks.
Let's go to I'm going to pronounce it correctly
this time.
Nesha from Michigan.
Did I get it right, Nesha?
Speaker 5: Yes, David, you got it right.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
What's going on?
Speaker 5: Nothing much.
I actually did talk to my friend that I talked
to you about, I guess, the last time that
I was on.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: It was like a pretty it was like
a trumpet's, but not a super crazy one.
Is that right?
Speaker 5: Yeah, she's well, she's definitely
not a tramp or anything like that.
She just doesn't really like she doesn't really
trust the, you know, the vaccine or whatnot.
Speaker 1: Oh, it was the vaccine.
OK, all right.
Fair enough.
OK, yes.
Speaker 5: The vaccine.
We kind of had a bit of a falling out.
Speaker 1: I really am I responsible for it?
Speaker 5: No, no, no, you're not OK, because
I told her that a friend of mine and another
friend of mine and her mother, they were fully
vaccinated.
And I was actually able to let them see my
child.
Right.
And once I think once I told her that, I think
she kind of got very defensive.
And then she asked me, why did I get the vaccine?
Because now I'm fully vaccinated.
Right.
So I pretty much, of course, had to go and
tell it.
Like the reason why I got my vaccination was
because to protect my daughter and also my
husband also got the same thing as well.
So.
I try to not get into a debate with her because.
She was asking me so many questions and then
she was bombarding me with all this stuff
and she was even telling me, of course, with
her whatever type of research that she had.
And I was like, well, where's your where's
your proof?
Where's proving why not?
It was like, well, I don't know.
Where did you get your stuff?
I read my stuff.
So, right, I just couldn't really.
Oh, man, and then I had to go and ask my husband
to pretty much help me out because he kept
on saying that the vaccine was pretty much
done and like in a matter of months and I
pretty much had to go and tell it like it
wasn't really in a matter of months.
It pretty much took over a decade, right?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I think my approach to when people say that
is, you know, sequencing the virus is a matter
of a few hours.
What the point here with these MRSA vaccines
is the underlying technology and that's been
researched for more than a decade.
Sequencing the virus is child's play and it
can be done in just a matter of hours, but
that this is a different type of vaccine.
And so just applying that kind of statement
doesn't really make sense because the underlying
technology has been in development for so
long.
Speaker 5: All right.
And because I think my husband has said that,
I think it's I think they started doing it,
I think back in 2003.
So pretty much almost I guess close to two
decades.
I thought maybe.
Speaker 1: Yeah, but Nesha, so are you guys
not no longer speaking because of the vaccine?
Differences of opinion
Speaker 5: pretty much have differences of
opinions.
Yeah.
He, of course, told me that her sister was,
of course, getting the vaccine and her mother
was too.
Yeah.
And she also she was infected with covid,
I think maybe maybe three weeks ago.
So she finally, of course, got out of it.
Yeah.
And that was pretty fascinating.
Like, don't you think that would at least
gotten the reason what's been a reason for
you to at least take the vaccine just so you
don't get sick anymore?
Right.
Because I kind of had sometimes some kind
of epiphany, like if you keep on getting sick
from the same virus over and over again, it
might I don't know, I could be wrong that
it might damage you in some type of way where
you can't really recover from it.
Speaker 1: Well, once you recover, you're
protected from that strain for some period
of time.
But it's not as robust protection is from
as from getting vaccinated.
Yeah, listen, hopefully the relationship can
be reconvened and rehabilitated.
And I really appreciate you giving me the
update, Nesha.
OK, all right.
Thanks very much.
All right.
There is Nesha from Michigan with an update
there.
Let's go next to a meal from Maryland, a meal
from Maryland.
You're on the air.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, thanks for pronounce
your name correctly.
My pleasure.
I wanted to ask you, have you been following
or if you heard about the ongoing situation
in Ethiopia?
Speaker 1: Not not if there's anything recent
I mean, generally speaking, I've been following
Ethiopia for four, ten years, but what's going
on right now?
Speaker 5: The well, the the terror crisis,
the civil war going on, the northern region
that has started in November.
You've heard about that.
Speaker 1: Yes, yes, yes.
Speaker 5: OK, I was curious what what is
the sort of the narrative, I guess, that you've
heard about it and I haven't really seen you
covered much on your show.
I'm curious why you haven't.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I just I just don't know
enough about it.
You know, one of the things I try not to do
on this show is that I just don't know enough
about I'm not the right person to give you
any kind of hot take or analysis of it.
I haven't covered it because I don't know
enough about it.
I've been so busy with other things, so I
just I don't want to comment on things I don't
know about.
Speaker 5: OK, yeah, no, I understand that
and I respect that.
I just wanted to say that the the situation
is really complicated in general.
There is there there are some people who have
an interest in putting out a genocide narrative.
And I just think that's really inconclusive
at this time.
There needs to be an investigation on the
atrocities that are happening because they
definitely are happening there.
There are some war crimes going on.
But I just really hope that the the U.S. and
the Biden administration doesn't pull some
kind of Libya or Syria type of intervention
that I just think that would be a really bad
disaster and really destabilize the region.
Speaker 1: All right.
Well, let me read up on it and I'll follow
up if I have some something to add.
Speaker 5: OK, cool, yeah, well, like I just
want to say, a lot of the stuff that is in
the Western media is I feel like a little
biased.
And from what I'm hearing from like internally
in the country, it's it's just a really complicated
situation.
And I feel like it's just me a while before
we really know what's what's actually
Speaker 1: that applies to most conflicts,
that the perspective from Western media is
relatively narrow and rarely does any perspective
fully tell us really what's going on in the
country.
I think that that's we should bring that approach
to our understanding of most situations.
Speaker 5: This is kind of made me rethink
a little bit the Israel Palestine conflict,
because I can kind of see how things can get
can get distorted.
You don't understand the history, but I just
think most people should be a little agnostic
on the situation.
We'll learn more in the coming years.
They're having a big election next month and
we'll see how things unfold after that.
Speaker 1: All right, Emile, thank you.
Speaker 6: Yeah, thanks, David.
Speaker 1: All right.
There is a meal from Maryland.